hi I'm Tom mcshay here with brian hong
from Namco Bandai and we're here to talk
about Dark Souls 2 so what I realize
with dark souls and demon souls before
is it has the most dedicated fan base of
just about any franchise I can think of
is there a reason why so many people are
drawn and then they are so excited and
immersed in this community yeah you know
I think it's because of many things but
one in particular that comes to my mind
is because of the way the game's story
is told to you are not told to you a lot
of it is kind of learned as you go
through and interact with NBC's a lot of
it is inferred and there's a lot of
sometimes speculation but a lot of
inference right so community members and
community leaders at their key ones like
you know you've got your epic named rose
and you've got your bud videos who are
you know helping that process along and
a lot of people want to talk to each
other so you know there's so many
different ways to tell a story in a game
and the medium that is a video game
there's so many different ways to do
that from software's chosen to do it in
a very specific way that's really off
the beaten path I think if you ask them
they'll tell you that it wasn't part of
the master plan to have this community
bite sprout out because the way that
they've told the story of the game but
definitely that is kind of a side effect
that there that has happened yeah one of
the things I realize is because the game
is both obtuse and difficult it's really
tough to get through without some
outside help it was almost like when i
was playing games 20 years ago and i
couldn't get through zelda without
asking you so do you think that is
helping the community grow together as
opposed to like the competitive
competitive communities which are a
little more antagonistic i guess yeah
you know i think you touched on a real
key point especially since we were
talking off family before you told me
you recently you know finish the game
and you you're such a big fan of it and
you are telling me even yourself about
you know how you got into the game and
it's a common thing that we hear from a
lot of folks is that they pick up the
game and they try it and then they give
it up and they say i don't know but then
when they pick it back up and they do it
a second time that light bulb goes on
and the music to my ears is when I've
talked to some other hardcore gamers and
they say man you know what it reminds me
of why I'm a gamer and what better way
to compliment you know an experience
that that you can have and to say
something like that right so a lot of
Triple A games come out and they sell a
lot and then they still lose money we
hear the stories all the time Dark Souls
sold about 2.4 million and I remember
from software being ecstatic about that
as there are similar realistic
expectations with dark souls 2 or is
there a bigger budget bigger investment
and you hope to get a bigger return also
yeah that's so that's a good question
they were ecstatic as where we mostly
because it was like wow we felt like you
know this is kind of an obtuse and
difficult game it's in a lot of ways it
is a niche game but yet who knew the
niche was this big he's open all these
people said i love this game right so
when we looked at it and we said hey
dark souls 2 what do we want to do no we
didn't go crazy with with our budgets we
wanted to make sure that all the all the
assets that we came out with and
although you know communications we're
still true to the game and we could
really get the word out but you know
it's that it's that analogy that that I
like to use actually we actually did
this during our strategic planning
meetings was did we make the game easier
should we make the game easier to make
it more appealing to a mass market to
try and get those dollars no was my
answer I mean he's at least from my
point of view because you look at
products like the Mac you know six seven
years ago everyone was talking about HPS
and the windows programs and that was
the dominant platform of laptops and the
Mac was just kind of humming along doing
its thing and it didn't change to meet
what the market was it stayed to what
the Mac was supposed to be in the vision
of the creators of the mac and what
eventually happened very organically was
the market actually came around to the
mac and realized this is a superior a
superior type of laptop and you know i'm
not speaking as a proponent of apple but
for me it was a very good exam
don't change your product to meet what
the market is stick to what your product
is meant to be in your own vision and
the people that share that vision will
eventually come to your product and that
was the analogy that I tried to give to
everybody at least on our side with dark
souls 2 from from my position from my
vantage point so you work exclusively on
Dark Souls and Dark Souls 2 what is the
most exciting thing about your job what
makes you excited to come to work well I
don't know that too many gamers out
there really care a whole lot about know
my type of job and then my job is
marketing and you know I'll share a
story about Dark Souls it was one of the
first games that they gave me to work on
when I got to this company and truth be
told I didn't know much about it so my
approach was ok what is unique about
this game and all I kept saying was how
hard this game was and a lot of people
said don't talk about how hard it is
because people won't want it I said
actually that's one of the reasons you
would want it it's almost like that big
giant freckle or a mole on somebody's
face where when they're young they're
self-conscious about it they get older
you're like that's the most beautiful
mall in the world so that's how we
embrace the death of the game that's how
we came up eventually with prepare to
die in their campaigns that's how we're
kind of approaching all the things about
Dark Souls I love the fact that it's
such a unique game quite honestly it's
pretty it's pretty fun and easy to
market a game let's like this because it
has its unique positioning filter thank
you so much for taking the time to talk
to us the game comes out March 11th on
the playstation 3 and xbox 360 and pc pc
is shortly thereafter okay well thank
you again thank you very much your wings
will burn in anguish time after time for
that is your fate
the fate
of the cursed